hello everyone this is the position from
the final game in the movie searching
for Bobby Fischer and the movies
portraying the early life of the
American prodigy Joshua Waitzkin and I'm
a big fan of Josh and I really enjoyed
this movie some people say it's terrible
some people really like it and I enjoyed
the movie for a couple reasons I enjoy
it and playing against the hustlers in
the part 1 of the hustlers is played by
Laurence Fishburne I really enjoyed the
part of his teacher bruce pandolfini and
you know i enjoy when i when Josh it's
probably the tournament starts in about
one month and Josh goes fishing with his
father and then when all the other kids
hear about it they're jealous because
they were forced study chess like one
minute till the tournament starts and
all in all I enjoyed the movie I watched
a lot of times and although in real life
Josh did win the United States
Championship and he drew the last game
but it was enough for him to win the
championship but in the movie they kind
of made it that he wins the last game so
this is the position from the final game
you can check it out and try to find a
winning move for black I mean it's not a
really a winning move it's 12 it's a 12
move sequence and josh is playing with a
black pieces and it's kind of an intense
moment Josh josh is having a
conversation with his opponent which
kind of isn't allowed during a chess
game but he's his teacher bruce
pandolfini is also explaining to
Joshua's father how he does have a win
in the position and that it's 12 moves
ahead but he can do it and indeed the
Josh does find it and he does it and he
even offered the draw to his opponent
but his opponent thought that he was
winning and refused the draw so let's
see how the game continued we have G G
captures on f6 we have Bishop captures
on f6 and now rook at the c6 check and
this is this is the move that George's
teacher wanted Josh to see we have King
to a5 and now rook captures on f6 would
check a temporary
change sacrifice we have night captures
on f6 now Bishop captures on f6 King
captures on f6 and Knight to d7 with
check for King the king and the rook we
have kinked five and now Knight captures
on e5 and King captures on e5 and this
was the whole point of the combination
to make this White King go to e5 and
although in the in the movie they are
portrayed as very strong players both
Josh and his opponent and any strong
player would see that this is completely
completely winning for black but in the
movie they make the scene seem kind of
intense okay so we have a five we have
h5 we have a 486 a three eight seven
eight two and here Josh's opponent is a
very impressed with himself as he plays
h8 and brings up a queen and after Josh
plays pawn to a-1 and brings up his own
Queen his opponent is extremely
surprised as well this came as a shock
to him and he plays King to f5 and Josh
simply picks up the Queen so it's a it's
a very thematic position and thematic
puzzle and well it's it's not it's not a
very good one at that I mean probably
probably they could figure out a better
better game to show in the movie but
like I said some people really enjoy the
movie some people say it's terrible so
I'm interested if you've seen it and
what do you think of the movie and maybe
maybe you have another chess movie to
recommend so yeah that's it thank you
all for watching as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and I'll
see you soon